this determinant 'no switch constitutes
the essential character of the thing and
distinguishes it from all others is now
defined in such a way that the thing is
thereby in opposition to other things
but it's supposed to preserve its
independence in this opposition but it
is only a thing or a one that exists on
its own account insofar as it does not
stand in this relation to others for
this relation establishes rather its
continuity with others and for it to be
connected with others is to cease to
exist on its own account it is just
through the absolute character of the
thing at its opposition that it relates
itself to others and is essentially only
this relating the relation however is
the negation of itself subsistence and
it is really the essential property of
the thing that is its undoing
we're now at you might say the gotcha
moments of perception this entire
section Kegel has been exploring the
nature of the thing as it is for
perception the object of perception its
relation to the perceiver what's going
on within it and in these paragraphs
that is 125 through 128 and even 129
he's going to talk about the thing being
essentially destroyed or being destroyed
as far as its essence goes games with
Linda going to ground being thinking
about throwing something on the ground
and we don't have a complete vanishing
of the thing but the thing as something
substantive as what it was that we are
going to take as our our getting point
as our launching off point is is now
going to reveal itself as not being
adequate to provide that to us and that
what's really going on is more on the
side of consciousness which saw itself
as being the in essential then what's
going on on the side of the thing so
let's see how that takes place
in 125 first says this determinant 'no
suits the essential character of the
thing what what is that that determinate
us
it's unity it's being a one as opposed
to being and also and distinguishes it
from all others is now defined in such a
way that the thing is therefore in
opposition to other things we've seen
this movement before with the thing and
its properties the properties were
opposed to each other now the things are
opposed to each other but this
opposition conceals a not quite identity
but at least similarity between the
things that are opposed why well insofar
as each one of them is a thing each one
of them is a unit and here in this
section and the sections that are going
to follow we see that unity strangely
enough isn't unified
there's an equivocal 'ti to the sense of
unity there's a hunger or a desire on
the part of unity to be something more
than it turns out to be I know that
sounds a little paradoxical but you'll
see what I'm talking about as we go
through this so all of these have unity
in common which means that insofar as
the things are unified ones they're all
pretty much the same they lack that
distinction you might say the unity is
cancelling out the opposition now that's
a problem because we won up the thing as
a unified whole to be something that
stands over and against other things so
he says it's only a thing or a one that
exists on its own account insofar as it
does not stand on this relation to
others for this relation this relation
of opposition establishes rather its
continuity with others it turns out that
seeming opposition gives way to
similarity or continuity or having
something in common and therefore not
existing entirely on its own this is
going to be an example that shouldn't
really strictly speaking be applied
right here in this portion of Hegel
because they have to do with persons not
with things but when we talk about
people you know wanting to differentiate
themselves from others and then
consumerism coming in and offering them
a whole plethora of ways in which you
know by buying something from the lands
and catalogue or whatever other
catalogue you want you can show what a
you know nonconformist standoffish
individual you are just like all the
others that's sort of what we're talking
about going on here this time at the
level of perception of things so he says
to be connected with others is to cease
to exist on its own account now that
doesn't mean to cease to exist entirely
but it means that the thing ceases to
exist on
zone account and this absolute character
that we're going to talk about it is you
might say call them to question we have
to ask well what is this absolute
character what does that possibly mean
he says it's just through the absolute
character of the thing it's opposition
Dan it relates itself to others and it
is essentially only this related so this
absolute character which we took is
being determinative giving the thing a
determinate ness of a skin-tight
specifying it as this thing turns out to
be a relation to other things he just
talks about one thing but we could think
about an entire manifold of things in
which the thing is losing itself he says
this relation however is the negation of
itself subsistence it turns out that the
unity the being by itself gives way
behind its own self opposing by its own
unfolding to this relatedness which
submerges the thing into a whole field
of other things it's really the
essential property of the thing that is
its own I'm viewing he says what do we
have going on here the typical
dialectical process where we have
something that you know appears to be
the way it is it self others it turns
out that there's more going on within it
it gives rise to its own opposition all
within it
consciousness looks on and says wait a
second what's going on here tries to
make sense of it and now that moves to
showing itself as at least at this point
inadequate
the conceptual necessity of the
experience through which consciousness
discovers that the thing is demolished
by the very deterministic constitutes
its essence and its being for self can
be summarized as follows the thing is
posited as being for itself or as the
absolute negation of all other nests
therefore as purely self related
negation but the negation that is self
related is the suspension of itself in
other words the thing has its essential
being in another thing
in Section 126 Hegel is following out
the implications of what we just talked
about in 125 and spelling them out and a
little bit more metaphysical detail but
he's also stressing that what is going
on here is that consciousness has an
experience of a kind of necessity no
vending kite the having to be a certain
way or you could think about it as we
want to play on words
a lack as well the experience of things
not being able to be as is that we'd
like them to be
what is it experiencing in all of this
well you know the thing is some sort of
determinate nasai mean we've stressed
this the entire time the thing has
properties the thing is salt the thing
is trunk the thing is a blue cloth the
thing is the camera but each thing
follows out this kind of trajectory this
dialectical process and the very
determinate nest of the stint ID the
being determined by the way I had a just
a little bit of a digression here what
are these these are suffixes right and
we use suffixes like that to indicate
the kind of substantive that is going on
where we take an adjective or we take a
verb and we turn it into a noun and a
noun is supposed to name a thing right
but this is a thing about a thing it's
really a quality of the thing the
quality of determinant is insofar as it
has determinate nough sits just like
everything else that is determinate that
it possesses determinate nough so we
don't want to be seduced too readily by
language into thinking that well it's
got determinate nough so that must be
something because what's going to happen
is the thing while I examining what it
means for it to be determinate as we've
just done in the preview
passages is showing us to be no thing
not a thing at least in the sense of
being something that can be totally
independent of all of its relations with
with everything else at least it doesn't
have an essence at this point or being
for itself we saw that it did but it's
being for itself is mediated so it's
better to say not that it doesn't have
any essence or that doesn't have being
for itself but rather it doesn't have it
simply it doesn't have it per se it
doesn't have it the way that we wanted
it to have it we've experienced
something in there
necessity means quite often you don't
get what you want right and so
consciousness is having that experience
right now now what does this mean the
being for itself Hegel tells us he
specifies here the thing is posited as
being for itself
here he's summarizing this process the
thing is is positive as being for itself
and what does that mean the absolute
negation of all other Ness that's that's
not to say that being for itself means
that at every single point in the entire
phenomenology but that's what it means
here with the thing being for itself
means negating all other mnestheus afar
as it is related to itself closes itself
off to everything else that's what
allows it to be a thing in the first
place to have a sort of per Durance to
have a sort of opposition is that it
closes in upon itself it's not
consciousness by the way that's doing
this consciousness is also for itself
but the thing Hegel thinks does this for
itself and what does that mean that
means he says that it is a purely self
related negation here's where it gets
really interesting if you pay close
attention to what's going on so it's a
purely self related negation what the
hell does that mean that's very abstract
as
a purely self related negation what
could that possibly add up to so it's
purely self related it is also a
negation at the same time we saw that it
was a negation we thought of all other
nests but since there isn't any other
nacelle or perfectly rounded sphere that
is constituting the thing it can only be
related to itself and so what is it
negating
it's negating itself what does that mean
that means that the thing has lost its
thing leanness or it's big night
you know ding height in german thickness
in english and where is its support
going to lie while he tells us here in
other words the thing has its essential
being in another thanks not in itself
but in another thing so it's essence
lies now outside of itself within
something else
in fact the definition of the object as
it is emerged has shown itself that
contain nothing else the object is
defined as having within it an essential
property which constitutes its simple
being for self but along with this
simple nature the object is also to
contain diversity which though necessary
is not to constitute its essential
determinants
this however is a distinction that is
still only nominal the UH nacelle which
is nonetheless supposed to be necessary
cancels itself out it is what has just
been called the negation of itself
in Section 127 Hegel is not letting up
he's just hammering away at the poor
thing saying here's a how you're wrong
here's how you're wrong here's how you
run and or not wrong so much but here's
how you don't measure up so he's going
to show us again we've been through all
this before you know the the thing has
an essential property of unity the thing
is what it is right a piece of chalk is
a piece of chalk and that is it's being
for itself so this is a way in which the
thing through it's essential property is
related to itself
we've just spelled out some of the
implications of that being for itself
there's still some yet to come so that's
one side of the thing of the object but
on the other side it's a diversity of
properties right and each of these
properties we saw is in a certain way a
sensuous Universal the thing itself is
being grasped through sense perception
and why does Hegel at this point use
this interesting language of saying that
this diversity of properties is
necessary to the thing well because
let's use this piece of chalk or think
about the old familiar salt example if
this is just whiteness it's not chalk
there has to be a diversity of
properties those properties cannot all
be the same they must be opposed to each
other so we need this structure there
that is necessary in order to have a
thing in order to have something that we
can perceive as an object of perception
but he goes on to say this is not here
we go
to constitute it's essential determinate
Ness it's necessary but it's not to
constitute it's essential determinate
nests this is not the same thing as this
and at the same time Hegel is going to
say this distinction that we're making
is only
nom-a-nom you know it's translated here
is nominal you could say a distinction
only in name like if you're gonna call
me dr. Sandler and also Gregory right or
the only people call me Gregory are
people who don't know me Greg right I am
the same object I am the same thing I'm
being discussed under different names
Hegel saying in a certain way what we
really says is this what we really
encounter what we really perceive as the
object and these are just aspects of it
but this side right here is as he points
out it's canceling itself out he says
this however is the distinction that's
only nominally unof central which is
nonetheless supposed to be necessary so
we have something that's necessary but
uh nacelle cancels itself out and we'll
talk about the German term there in a
second
it is what has just been called the
negation of itself so in Section 126
when we came up with this negation of
itself which led us by the way to what
the other thing alright what we've got
going on here is the process okay all
right there's a term that you you need
to know for Hegel we've talked about
this many times in this case it says it
hate Z's up up right so it sub leads
itself it cancels itself out it's
something active it is doing something
to itself this raises on some issues
well we just thought that it doesn't
actually have a self a determine itself
so how the hell is it doing that that's
what we're going to talk about in the
next section
with this the last insofar that
separated being for self from being for
another falls away on the contrary the
object is in one in the same respect the
opposite of itself it is for itself
insofar as it is for another and it is
for another insofar as as it is for
itself
it is for itself reflected into itself a
one but this for itself this reflection
and being this being a one is posited in
a unity with its opposite with its being
for another and hence only as cancelled
in other words this being for self as
just as unalaq that was supposed to be
unofficial that is the relationship to
another
Hegel is now bringing these reflections
to a close or at least to a not in
telling us that the final in so far that
has been separating being for self and
being for another in the object in the
thing that is being perceived now falls
away so the distance between these is is
lost interestingly there's going to be
some more insofar as we're going to see
right and what we've got going on here I
deliberately used an X here because we
have what's called the key astok
structure like key azzam is an X so we
have being for another showing up here
with a beginning for self showing up
here you know whenever you say something
that has this sort of structure it's a
rhetorical way of putting things in
terms of an X we call that a key us from
the Greek word for for X well stuff for
X actually that's that's a different one
that's a different letter but it looks
like an X right the P so what does he
annual saying here this distinction
between being for self and being for
another is breaking down and it's
breaking down in some rather interesting
ways
I usually don't skip right to the very
end of a passage but I'm gonna do that
in this case because look at what he's
saying here being for self is just as uh
nacelle as the only aspect that was
supposed to be uh nacelle that is the
relation to another
so before we at least had well you know
one part of the thing is really in
essential and we're jumping around like
well is it this / no this turns out to
be an essential is it this part over
here and we're going back and forth
now Hegel is actually going to say jokes
been on us both of them are in essential
neither one of us gives to us what the
thing really is why that's what we want
to find out in this section so let's
follow what he says the object is in one
of the same respect the opposite of
itself
how is it the opposite of itself the way
he explains that is saying that it's
being for self or it is for itself
insofar as it is for another now let's
actually plan chart out for ourselves
what that means this means that it has
that essentiality it has that close it
in in this it has that relatedness to
itself insofar as it is for another as
we've seen the thing requires at least
one other thing in order for itself to
have its being for stuff in order for
itself just you can't you know the get
abused sort of anthropomorphic things
you can't turn your back on somebody if
there's nobody else to turn your back on
it doesn't make any difference turning
your back on a book you need another
person to turn your back on the thing
needs another thing but that means that
it has to give up to a certain extent
that that you know pure self sufficiency
of the being for self in being for
another it has to make it so vulnerable
to the other you might say along with
this he says that being for another or
it exists for another it is for another
insofar as it is for itself
what does that mean well it can't be for
another if it isn't in the first place
if it doesn't have the kind of presence
if it's merely a whiteness and not a
piece of chalk
it can't be an object for me if it's
merely stripes and not a suit jacket it
can't be an object for me and these two
can't be in relation to each other I'm
not going to draw on this because I get
enough chalk on me but you get the idea
they can't exercise their relation to
each other except insofar as they are
objects more than just batches of
qualities being for another it's being
for another requires that it be for
itself so we have this key astok
structure here and we have another
insofar as occurring at this point so
what does this mean he says it is for
itself
reflect
into itself being for self means being a
one right but this for itself this
reflection into itself this being of one
is positive in a unity with its opposite
so it's unity with its opposite requires
that it be a one its oneness requires
that it be in a unity with its opposite
it can't just be a one it can't just be
in a unity with its opposite we could
continue this key astok structure in
this intervening over and over and over
again if we wanted to so what is the
upshot of this he says it's cancelled
this sorry it is the cancellation of
this this is the cancellation of this
this is where we get to the end point in
other words as being for self the unity
is just as in uh nacelle as the other
aspect that was supposed to be an
essential the relationship to another so
it turns out that where we were putting
our eggs into one basket the basket of
unity of oneness that's not going to be
an essential point either so the
question is where do we go from here
you